salut j'ai une nouvelle excellente
aujourd'hui j'ai découvert un truc qui
est super génial aujourd'hui en très
grand fan des objets connectés
j'ai une watch d'apple et je suis très
heureux les mots connectés j'adore ça
j'attends le principe est ce que
vraiment c'est une avancée technologique
et je suis aussi un très grand fan des
jeux vidéo j'y joue plus depuis un petit
moment
je voulais normale grâce au casque
réalité virtuelle de sony et mais j'ai
joué pendant des années pendant des
années j'ai commencé à jouer sur un
amstrad cpc 464 à cassette
mon tout premier ordinateur avec mes
premiers jeux mon premier street fighter
fin bref je te passe l'histoire et à
l'époque elle aussi les à paris reste
inconnue les atari qui avaient des jeux
qui sont devenues mythiques
on développe tous pourris par rapport à
ce qui est aujourd'hui mais c'est
vraiment voilà c'est rentré dans la
légende
atari c'est sartre et à la la balle j'ai
fait le logo est aujourd'hui j'ai vu sur
le web d'une marque avait allier les
deux atari le chef vidéo et les mots
connecter pour faire une monde connecté
atari avec des jeux atari et ça c'est
génial car viens je t'emmène sans le web
et on va regarder ça ensemble
donc je suis sur un site qui s'appelle
zebulon.fr il en parle justement c'est
une smart watch qu'ils appellent la
smart roitg gail bornes le marché
diamant contessa spécialistes dont
qu'ils expliquent un petit peu que les
mondes connectés ou un petit peu de mal
et que le marché est en berne
mais par contre voilà il explique qu'il
ya un constructeur fmi tout games a
décidé de faire un pari différent en se
lançant sur le marché la smartwatch
celui de cibler le public des joueurs
excellente idée j'ai envie de te dire
donc il ya un design qui est magnifique
des fonctionnalités je dirais
traditionnel c'est surtout qu'ils vont
proposer les nombreux
jeux mythiques du catalogue atari
asteroids pong breakout centipede est
encore crystal castle c'était juste
génial
alors effectivement des jeux tu vas en
trouvait aussi sur la rage tue vont
trouver sur pas mal d'autres
mais l'idée de la dédier à tahri c'est
vraiment une excellente idée alors
effectivement elle s'adresse aux
nostalgiques de la célèbre maison
otaries comme aux jeunes joueurs la
nouvelle génération parce que voilà
atari st estève une référence alors ils
ont fait un financement participatif 1
sur kickstarter pour lancer un petit peu
je dirais leur projet z de 75000 dollars
et ils ont largement atteint l'objectif
ils ont eu plus 1000 contributeurs et
155 mille dollars et y rester encore un
mois de campagne tu te rends compte du
truc ça veut dire qu'en réalité il ya
une vraie demande et qu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup de personnes qui seraient
heureux de retrouver cette ambiance
atari cette ambiance jeu vidéo
directement dans leur montre si tu vas
sans leur projet kickstarter
donc là on voit un petit peu les proto à
quoi ça devrait ressembler te reconnais
bien le logo atari ici tu la vois au
poignet franchement c'est une nuit
magnifique fait voir la vidéo quoi elle
ressemble weekend esportif abritera les
incroyables
ils ont vraiment fait un truc de fou ça
vraiment ça promet quoi les mecs le
bracelet en cuir tu vois là elle a
vraiment un côté hyper classe petite
couture verte
ça rappelle un peu les icônes c'est
celle là la plus belle quand même hyper
sobre avec le guattari elle est
magnifique elle est vraiment super
rebelle basé sur un os propriétaire
dérivé d'android la game bonne pour la
game bande pourra donc être appareiller
un smartphone pour afficher les
notifications de ce dernier qui
apparaîtront sur l'écran amoled de 1 63
pouces avec une définition de 300 par 23
pixels 300 par 320 par 320 pixels je
vais y arriver il y aura donc un
processeur snapdragon were 2100 et pour
être 512 mégaoctets de ram mémoire
interne de 4 gigas quand même c'est pas
mal non dispo
également d'un port microsd pour spammer
très qui permettra de stocker davantage
de données dont les jeux ou encore les
photos
à l'instar d'une montre a tjs standard
la game boy la game bande disposera de
diverses applications de base comme le
lecteur audio une application météo au
calendrier ça ça reste la base quand
même dû montre connecter un site a pas
ça c'est quand même un petit peu dommage
donc du bluetooth du wifi jusque là on
est d'accord côté tarifs
normalement pour 149 dollars il est
possible de la précommande et donc au
final ça reste pas hyper hyper cher une
édition standard ou une édition atari la
game band c'est évident qu'il faut
l'édition au tarif qui ne s'adaptent pas
réellement d'intérêt
les premières livraisons seront prévues
pour le mois de septembre 2010 et je te
dis que septembre 2010 est ça va être
une rentrée qui avec un nouvel iphone 8
cette montre là je pense qu'il va y
avoir des choses qui vont se passer ça
va être vraiment sympa donc voilà ça je
voulais en parler ça donne vraiment
envie nouvellement connectés mais pas
n'importe laquelle elles se basent
vraiment sur une histoire ait survécu
c'est sur l'histoire d'appareils à tarik
el haouz et ça c'est vraiment génial
alors effectivement les jeux par rapport
à ce qu'on va pouvoir trouver son marché
par rapport à ce qui existe ça reste un
petit peu cheap ça reste des jets [ __ ]
et ça ça va être tout simplement
extraordinaire je te laisse des infos
dans la description si tu veux en savoir
plus
va voir le cantique starter
indirectement du fabricant il y aura
aussi les liens vers les vidéos pour
avoir plus d'infos sur cette montre dis
moi ce que t'en penses dis-moi si toi tu
auras envie de la voir
est ce que tu as déjà une montre
connectés est-ce que tu as une gouache
d'apple est ce que tu es plutôt samsung
voilà comment on se situe par rapport à
tout ça quels sont tes attentes par
rapport au monde connecté moi je sais
que j'ai la mienne je suis très heureux
parce que voilà il ya plein de choses
que je peux gérer des listes de courses
la météo ces pratiques les photos
commandées son iphone à distance c'est
génial mais je te cache pas que celle là
elle me donne vraiment envie
en complément de celles là la voir en
deuxième montre si je devais en choisir
une dès le départ je suis pas sûr de
prendre celle là mais d'aller plutôt sur
la watch parce qu'elle est en complément
de mon iphone et je suis un
gros gros gros fan d'apple ça tu le sais
tu as déjà regardé les vidéos avant
totalement
donc voilà dis moi ce que t'en penses
regardez cette vidéo là elle est aussi
très sympa abonne toi je te remercie et
à très vite en commentaire ciao